hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
notions that Kant makes constant
reference to in the groundwork of the
metaphysics of morals in addition to
that of the good will and you know
complex things that are a little bit
harder to wrap our heads around like
autonomy and Ronna me priori things like
that is this word duty and it comes up
over and over and over again and I've
seen students get mixed up about this
quite quite often Kant has a very
important precise understanding of what
it is for an action to actually or
abolition a willing to be not only in
accordance with duty but done from duty
that's what gives an action or a
volition it's more worth and cons view
that's what makes a will a good will so
when we're trying to understand the
nature of the good will the one good
thing that's that's good without
qualification according to Kant
we're looking at this this conception of
Duty we want to make sense out of the
concept of a will as he says estimable
in itself good apart from any further
end now that's going to involve duty
but simply doing what we normally
conceive of as our duties the things
that we want to do that doesn't get us
to where we need to be and that doesn't
actually address this in the way that
cotton wants to leave us
so let's actually look at this what he
calls the concept of Duty itself not
just the experience of having duties you
know like say being assigned chores or
having made a promise to a friend and
feeling yourself under an obligation to
to fulfill that obligation that you've
undertaken the promise that you've made
not just legal duties not just you know
duties that are connected with rights
that we have as things that we know in
our society so for instance if you have
a right to free speech that's granted to
to you by by the state I am supposed to
not interfere with your free speech
right there's a lot of different ways
that could happen though and that's why
it's so important for Kant to get away
from these experiential what he calls
empirical ways of wrapping our head
around
we want to think about the mere concept
the pure concept of Duty and he says
that this includes the concept of a
goodwill so within the conception of
actually doing duty or following Duty or
fulfilling Duty is a certain way of
orienting ourselves towards it a certain
way of making ourselves do it so it's
not just a sort of external getting
ourselves in line with what it is that
we are told we ought to do but don't
really feel like doing that constitutes
Duty if we think about the concept
itself there's something a bit deeper
something a bit more rich something a
bit more that was yeah I guess you could
say cure involved and when he talks
about the idea of a goodwill he also
says that the the goodwill
we're understanding in terms of duty has
what he called subjective limitations
and obstacles and because he doesn't
tell you what those are you might just
pass over that part of the text and say
yeah yeah that's all sorts of you know
philosophers stuff but there really is
something important that even he's he's
getting at there so let's go through
this bit by bit and this this section
and see what we can dig up so he says
we're trying to elucidate the concept of
a will good apart from any further end
this concept which is already present in
a sound natural understanding and
requires not so much to be taught as to
be clarified how do we clarify it by
thinking it through by stripping away
some of the preconceptions that we have
about it and really figuring out what
lies at the roots so he says we're going
to take up the concept of duty and these
subjective limitations and obstacles
don't actually hide a good will or
disguise that they bring out by contrast
and make it shine more brightly and it
says I'm gonna adhere these it's going
to divide actions up into a couple
different types so if we have actions or
Volition's you know things that we do
things that we will but maybe don't
actually bring about they can be against
duty or they can be in agreement with
you alright
some reactions right from the start are
going to be clearly immoral poisoning a
person it doesn't really matter for Kant
what sort of reason you did it for it
goes contrary to your duty deliberately
telling a person something that is
untrue which will get them terribly main
door in
there's no way from a Content
perspective that you're gonna make that
part of your duty yeah that's going to
be in accordance with duty that's always
going to be a bad action there's certain
things that's one of the nice things
about conch in moral theory whether you
agree with it or disagree with it it is
very clear on certain certain things
certain things are clearly against duty
so we're not going to worry about that
so much we're interested now in actions
that are actually in agreement with duty
so we're doing the thing that you want
to do you're engaging in the action that
you want to be doing you're actually
choosing that action that's what it
means have a free will you're choosing
to do that thing that action you're
choosing that policy that course towards
the world towards other people towards
yourself towards the things that you you
have control over the question is why
are you doing it what is what Kat calls
your motive what is your purpose behind
that action or that volition so here's
where there's a fundamental dividing
line there it's possible to do the right
thing but to do it for what considers to
be not necessarily the wrong reasons but
not the right reasons the only right
reason is ultimately because it's the
right thing to do because it is your
duty because you choose to will in
accordance with and from duty you make
that your sole motive anything else what
you call some other motive or principle
is going to make the action not
necessarily immoral something against
duty but it's going to deprive it of its
moral worth so you could say that it
becomes a moral or non moral the only
thing that's truly moral that has moral
worth our actions that are in agreement
with duty and that are done from the
motive
so he gives you some examples these are
ones that he considers later on you know
a grocer or any merchant who is giving a
fair price to customers right now if he
gives the unfair price to customers he
screws some people over he's doing
something that goes against duty he
should give a fair price right the
question is why is he doing it why is he
giving a fair price is he doing that
because he recognizes that that's the
right thing to do and he actually does
that in every circumstance even when it
doesn't necessarily pay off for him or
you know translate into some benefit or
fulfill some other thing that he wants
to achieve
where is he doing the good action the
right thing because he's motivated by by
something else in that case it's not
really the good action that he is
choosing for you know for himself he's
choosing that as a means to a certain
end and the end could be any of these
sort of things and these these overlap
quite a bit he gives some examples with
the grocer right maybe the grocer is
acting out of self-interest maybe he
thinks you know yeah I better not
overcharge people because if I do that
the cops are gonna come in or they're
gonna bust me or people are gonna get
wise to this and say hey don't go to him
he screws you over it's kind of random
there could be all sorts of things where
somebody you know reasons this out and
says I shouldn't do the wrong thing I
should do the right thing but I should
do it because it's good business you
know you often hear this in business
ethics people say why should businesses
be ethical well because it improves the
bottom line well that would be you know
a perfect example of what count is
talking about here that's not that you
know that's very far from doing the
right thing we're being ethical because
it's important to be ethical if you're
doing it just because it improves the
bottom line or keeps your public image
alive it keeps you out of trouble then
you're doing it for some other reason
than then because it's the right thing
let's say that's not a you know fully in
line with duty
what else immediate inclination maybe he
loves everybody
maybe he's the kind of person who's just
personable and enjoys dealing with with
people and customers and so he wants to
give them a fair price because he feels
good towards them right you could say
the same thing about teachers maybe you
know do I have a duty to teach my
students and to make sure that all of
them actually learn yes now why well
because I'm getting paid because if I
don't do that I'll get in trouble
because I just happen to like these
people and I enjoy the act of teaching I
would say any of those sort of things
are getting away from doing Duty for its
own sake other inclinations you know
there's another number of different
possible inclinations that we have that
could could they do this maybe somebody
says I am going to do the right thing
because I want to carry out an
experiment with my life I want to see
what doing the right thing will bring it
out for me and I'm not necessarily
trying to obtain some sort of beneficial
good or you know enjoyable good for
myself I'm just curious well that
wouldn't be acting out of out of duty
either that would be acting in
accordance with duty but not from do our
feelings you know we tend to look at it
as a good thing if we have good feelings
towards other people God says well
they're not bad you know it's good to
have good feelings towards other people
but it's not morally good it's not
something that that makes an action or a
willing a choice on your part something
that's morally good so you know you give
some some other examples here which I'm
going to skip over you want to get to a
little bit further on he talks about he
doesn't makes a distinction here he says
it's Douglas in this sense we should
understand the passages for
scripture in which were commanded to
love our neighbor neither even our enemy
love out of inclination cannot be
commanded you can have it right you can
be inclined to love other people even to
love enemies but you can't command that
but kindness done from duty although no
inclination impels us and even though
natural and in conquerable
disinclination stands in our way
is practical in that pathological love
residing in the will and not in the
pretensions of feeling you know the idea
that he's getting at here is that when
we're acting from duty for the sake of
duty not out of consideration of what
we're going to get out of it for some
inclination because we're already sort
of headed in that that direction but we
make ourselves do that in a certain way
there's a purity of will present that's
not present in in these cases there's
much more that can be said about that
but I'm not going to try to unpack that
here then he gives us a few propositions
and these are important when it comes to
duty as well so I'm actually going to
erase some of this stuff over here so we
can sort of unpack these the first one
is basically along the lines of what I
was just erasing telling us that we
should act I would have duty we should
will we should act out of duty not just
in accordance with duty so
understand out of motivated by okay so
that's the first thing that we can say
about about duty
another thing that he says is an action
done from duty has its moral worth and
not in the purpose to be attained by it
but in the maximum in accordance with it
with which it is decided upon it depends
therefore not on the realization of the
object of the action but solely on the
principle of volition in accordance with
which the action has been for performing
so there's a lot of jargon here let's
put down some of this so we can we can
make some sense of this there's a term
that he's using here that we want to
focus on an action done from duty as
it's more worth so it is good morally
good not from its purpose not from the
effects that you're trying to achieve by
it by its maxim in accordance with which
it is decided so another way of putting
this if we wanted to use some concrete
examples would be to say that when we're
acting and we're doing the right thing
we're choosing the right thing what
makes it good
is not the purpose of the action what it
is that the action is supposed to bring
about but the form or the kind of thing
that we're willing the description that
we could give to it so you know think
for example about giving water to a
thirsty person out in the desert right
what are you sort of classical movie
motifs some guy is crawling around sand
water water you've got a canteen of
water you give it to him he drinks the
water you've done a good thing what made
it good now in a certain sense it's good
because you know his body stays alive
and all that in cat says yeah yeah
that's that that's fine we're interested
in the moral goodness of the action now
so when you actually gave him the
canteen when you chose to do that
instead of saying well screw you I'm
gonna go over here or I need to keep my
water for myself or you know everyone's
got their own water you you you know
you've obviously used up yours when
you've decided to give him your water it
wasn't that you had this purpose of say
feeling good or keeping God happy with
you or keeping this guy alive
or any of the actual empirical effects
of it it was you deciding on a certain
Maxim a certain rule that that describes
the kind of action the kind of willing
that you're engaged in so the the
maximun that's where the case would be
something along the lines of whenever I
see a person in need of resources which
I have at my disposal and can grant to
that person I will in fact grant those
resources to that person there's other
ways we could describe that Maxim
it's that Maxim that makes the action
done from duty good so even if it
backfired
or even if I had other inclinations I
was like you know showing off for
somebody let's say I was kind of you
know mixed mind about this if I was
actually forcing myself to do it
nevertheless because I recognized that
that's the sort of action that a person
ought to do because it's that kind of
action
that meets that sort of maxim then my
action would have moral worth my choice
would have moral value the other thing
that he says that it's particularly
important he talks about a third
proposition that's an inference from
these others
he says Duty is the necessity to act out
of reverence for the law duty is assess
the reverence for the law and what law
does he actually mean moral not just any
old law but the moral cut thinks that
although we don't follow it all the time
and we don't recognize it much of the
time within the human being because the
human being is rational there is a moral
law which we can come to recognize a
moral law includes these things that we
call Maxim's certain kinds of Maxim's
tells us that we ought to do this we
ought not to do this tells us what sort
of dispositions to a certain degree we
ought to have what kind of beings we
ought to make of ourselves so Duty is
going to be involving on the person's
part the person who is actually acting
out of duty
he has a kind of reverence for the moral
law they recognize it as being something
valuable for its own sake not because
it's good business or because it makes
them happy or because God likes it or
because mom and dad told you you need to
do it or any of those sorts of reasons
it's good because it is good because it
is the moral law and for cut you you
reach a certain bedrock point where you
know he can keep on giving you all sorts
of other deductions and reasonings when
you reach a certain bedrock point where
if somebody says well yeah but why
should I have reverence for the moral
law Kant would actually have to look at
it and say because you ought to that's
that's what it means for it to be the
moral law it's the kind of thing that
you ought to have reverence for and now
that's not a word that we use an awful
lot these days
what does reverence mean you know
practically speaking reverence is not so
much about feeling a certain way as
about choosing and behaving a certain
way you tell what a person has reverence
for by the structure of their their
actions the patterns of their reactions
the fabric of the life that they form
the character that they display so
somebody who has reverence for example
for the flag would be willing to
actually charge up the hill to you know
fight other people to keep the flag from
dipping it's kind of a some ways a
trivial thing but you know when somebody
has reverence for the flag hopefully
it's not just that that piece of faux
fabric up there it's because they have
reverence for what it represents when
somebody has reverence for the moral law
that means that they when push comes to
shove when inclination sets up obstacles
and says hey let's you know cut a corner
here you don't have to be so rigorous
the person says no this is actually
precisely in the sort of case where I
need to be rigorous because that's what
it means
actually recognized duty not just as
something that's imposed on somebody
from from without as you know a chore as
a regulation as an imposition but as
something that you you say yeah as a
reasonable person I see this is what I
ought to do this is the right thing and
even though I don't really feel like
doing it I got to make myself somehow do
this right thing that's what it would be
to act from duty and you notice all
three of these imply each other they
they connect with each other they
reinforce each other so this is this is
what Kant means by duty as being the
motive of the goodwill it's not
something that you can reduce just to a
bunch of examples this is something that
he thinks you have to think out as a
concept I think it is helpful to use
examples to make sense of this and you
know we did a few in this condom self
uses a few examples but ultimately it
comes down to these sorts of rules so
that's that's the conception of duty